I think privacy because I'm my privacy
as much as anyone but I think as a
social good a social ass I think privacy
is it's greatly overrated because
privacy basically means concealment
people conceal things in order to fool
other people about about them you know
when I appear healthier than they are
smarter more honest so forth so so I
don't I don't think I mean I'm
exaggerating some but I think it's a
very much a double-edged sword as a from
a social stamp last number one number
two privacy is is not one of those
things I think that's deeply ingrained
in the human nature I think it's very
culturally specific obviously early man
early people had no privacy they
couldn't afford it it says it's what
it's what economists call a superior
good the demand for it rises as as
people become wealthier because it has
this you know this instrumental value
you do want to control information about
yourself that will enable you to make
advantageous transactions personal and
professional and commercial with other
people so but so is this I don't think
it's deeply ingrained in us I think it's
culturally specific and part because it
isn't deeply ingrained it turns out that
people obviously as I attach some value
to privacy because it does is nice to be
able to conceal the bad things about
yourself but they don't attach a lot of
value to it and that's indicated by the
behavior the way we surrender our
privacy for really small gains like if
you if you deal online do you reveal
enormous in
to the vent doors then they exchange it
among themselves and if the government
wants it from them can get it easily so
with one click one click purchasing from
Amazon what that means that you give
Amazon all the information about your
your reading habits they they create a
profile of you so they can they just
want to sell you the books they do
they're not stupid but they use this
information create a profile secreting
basically a political or cultural
profile of you people turn out to be
willing to surrender privacy for quite
modest gains like the convenience of the
one-click ordering also for example now
medical records are increasingly being
digitized well once they're did when
something is digitized it's it's out
there your privacy is lost because I'm
not sure everybody realizes this but
digitized materials tend to serve tend
to tend to be in sort of multiple copies
on different servers and so forth so but
on the other hand it's a great
convenience to have your medical records
digitized so that's the that's the
that's the inexorable trend all your
medical information they won't be
completely public but it'll be
accessible in a way that handwritten
doctor's notes are or not and similarly
with easy pass your your movements are
recorded permanently and now Chicago
probably New York I know in the Wall
Street area and of course London most
famously are installing surveillance
cameras in the in the lampposts
basically so people's movements are are
traceable they're being observed
employees use their their computers at
work for all sorts of personal stuff but
that's monitored by employers or can be
monitored by Berbers they have no
legally protected interest in it so
there's some moves to create new privacy
rights but it's overwhelmed by the
convenience of surrendering your privacy
and it's a fact that people surrender it
for other small gains is is a sign them
really or most people really value at
that punch party because it's very much
a relative kind of good if everybody
else is concealing a lot of information
about himself
then you'd be kind of a fool to have it
all hanging out right but as more and
more people become transparent your that
becomes kind of a social norm which you
tend to conform to because people are
very imitative of each other and so I
think yeah and of course privacy can be
very dangerous obviously if you're if
you're terrorists privacy is enormous ly
important so the more we think of
privacy as endangering us that will
reinforce these commercial incentives to
surrender privacy but as I say we lived
for millennia with very little privacy
and you know people didn't see seemed
able to cope with that quite well so I
wouldn't regard it as a